imagine you are a newly joined software
engineer perhaps a front-end developer
by trade and you've been asked to fix a
bug in the backend code base and what
are some challenges you can face
probably the back end is written in a
language you're unfamiliar with or maybe
it's a language you know but the bigger
question is where do you even start
where do you look for the issue without
getting lost in the complexity of the
code or let's imagine you've been tasked
to create an API from scratch in this
situation how how do you form the mental
map of the code base stick to the
standards and ensure you're not breaking
anything one scenario could be you are a
backend engineer in typescript or goang
and you're suddenly asked to jump into a
different language let's say rust or
python now how do you get up to speed
quickly without wasting hours looking
through docks of different libraries
let's say fast API or uh pedantic or for
rust it's it could be Axiom or any other
Library it could be an orm like SQL
Alchemy or diesel so the question is how
do you apply your existing knowledge in
a new environment without Reinventing
the wheel now this is where learning
back and from first principles becomes
invaluable the ability to break down
complex systems into their most basic
and Universal components gives you a
massive Edge like one
seeing the big
picture right when you enter an existing
codebase instead of being overwhelmed by
its structure or the complexity of its
engineering you can mentally separate
out the different parts of the system
and work on them in an isolated way
you'll be able to identify the core
Logic the routing layers the database
connections and the over engineered
pieces and by filtering out these noises
you can start making changes or fixing
bugs with confidence and this is
something you might have noticed in
senior Engineers or ctOS or cosos they
can just look at any code or any
particular code base and they'll quickly
get a fair idea of what's going on or
where the buck could be because a human
brain is very good at picking up
patterns senior Engineers or ctOS they
subconsciously pick up these patterns so
they don't have to actually use this
deliberately but my question is why wait
for years of experience you can
deliberately practice from day one and
get good at this in let's say 6 months
or 1 year now the second thing is faster
onboarding
when you understand the first principles
behind backend engineering like how HTTP
Works how databases interact with apis
or how requests flow through the
middleware you can dive into any
language or framework and find your way
around it you no longer need to spend
hours going over Library specific dogs
once you have learned the Core Concepts
behind authentication or routing or
middleware and database interaction the
syntax is secondary you'll be able to
cut through the noise focusing on the
logic instead of the syntax this allows
you to develop a deep sense of
familiarity with a codeb much faster
than if you're focused solely on syntax
or language specific features now the
third thing is 10x
faster in new
projects when you start a new project
from scratch having backend knowledge
grounded in first principles helps you
move with Incredible speed and precision
you'll be able to create MVPs with
production quality code far faster
because you'll be working from a deep
understanding of the systems needs not
just following boiler plate tutorials
you'll know how to structure your routes
set up database connections and
Implement critical functionalities like
caching or error handling or logging
without constantly referencing
documentations and the fourth
is
syntax
fatig learning a new language can be
overwhelming enough but if you're unsure
of what concepts to learn next after
grasping the syntax or if you don't know
how to apply that syntax to solve actual
problems uh backend engineering problems
can lead to frustration or even burnout
first principles reduce this syntax
fatigue because once you understand the
fundamental building blocks switching
between languages is no longer a
daunting task you know the problems you
are solving and now it's just about
applying the right syntax and libraries
so for example you work as a nodejs
developer and you want to transition
into a rust backend engineer right so
how do you do it you'll obviously look
for a complete end to endend project of
how to create a back end in Rust uh at
least four and 5 hours and it has to
also maintain all the production quality
standards now the problem with that is
rust is a fa in new language and the
amount of resources that we have for
node the amount of Project based
resources that we don't have for rust so
how do you get good at it right and you
constantly worry about it I'm not
finding any projects I'm not finding any
good resources you're good at basic
syntax right how to handle different
types of data structures in Rust and
write basic programs but how do you
cross that threshold and actually build
an end to-end production quality project
so this is where the principles come in
so imagine you understand the different
layers of the back end for example you
start from routing and you go to
middleware and uh there is database
interactions there is logging there is
error handling and there is Asing code
everything right you understand all the
different components clearly as Concepts
and in noes so what is the next step you
understand basic Syntax for rust right
so you start a rust project with
whatever project layout that is
recommended by the community and you
target each component separately you
know how a production quality code looks
like for routing you know how it looks
like for validation and you know how it
looks like for data interactions and
repository pattern and handlers and
authentication authorization you know
all the good patterns now you just have
to convert your rust based syntax into
that pattern let's say you want to
tackle validation so you go look up how
to do validations in Rust you most
probably will find a library or some
kind of standard Library pattern of
implementing validations now you know
the syntax and you already know what are
the best practices and patterns and you
now you mix them up now you have a
module of validation in Rust which is
production quality and now you keep
repeating this pattern for every single
module let's say for authentication and
for all your rest API logic and in no
time in 2 3 days you'll have a fully
fledged production quality codebase in
Rust now the next thing is choosing the
right tool for the right job and this is
something I see Engineers face a lot of
problems with every day right because we
are stuck with our labels we think we
are a nodejs backend developer or we are
a ruby backend developer when we Face
requirement that we have to build this
module which has to have very high
concurrency demands right or a very low
latency demands so we are stuck with
whatever language that we usually work
with and the confidence to reach out for
the best tool we cannot get hold of that
by understanding the core problems back
in engineering sols data persistence or
request handling security scaling you'll
also gain the ability to choose the the
right tool for the right job you won't
be limited by your framework or your
language or your library you'll know
exactly which tool to use which language
to use and which framework to use you'll
understand when it makes sense to use
something like redis for caching or
postgress for relational data or mongodb
for unstructured data or let's say Kafka
for realtime even streaming independent
of the text tag you're currently working
with and the last thing
is
more employable
and this is what most of us want right
in today's rapidly changing Tech
landscape being able to apply your bag
knowledge across languages and
Frameworks makes you incredibly
versatile and thus more employable
employers want Engineers who can think
critically independently who can join
any team and begin contributing value
quickly by mastering backend principles
you become that adaptable engineer who
is not confined by a specific language
or stack but in state has the ability to
solve problems in any environment now
the good news is that you don't need to
wait for years of experience to develop
these skills you can start deliberately
practicing today by focusing on the Core
Concepts that remain the same across
every backend system like routing
database or authentication you can build
your own internal compass for navigating
new territories the goal is not just to
solve problems when they arise but to do
so with confidence and efficiency and
with time you will develop a Natural
Instinct for approaching any backend
code base or project no matter how
unfamiliar it may seem at first now
learning backend from first principles
elevates you from a framework specific
developer to a true software engineer
one who is not limited by a particular
stack or toolet but understands the core
problems backend engineering solves this
Freedom allows you to explore new
languages Frameworks and architectures
with ease and positions you as a
valuable asset in any engineering team
so whether you are a front-end developer
looking to expand your skill set or a
backend engineer wanting to transition
into a new language learning backend
from first principles will supercharge
your growth and Empower you to build
your own robust scalable and
maintainable system in any environment
so what are these principles anyway and
when I say principles I don't mean a
list of Rules by first principles I mean
some foundational blocks or foundational
components around which the rest of the
code base revolves at all times no
matter how small or how big it is a
generic map of the backend engineering
territory which helps you find the way
and we will start exploring the map from
the very next video